guten morgen aufwachen
es ist zeit zum aufstehen in der küche
steht das frühstück bereit
zieh dich an und kommt dann in die küche
ich hole
sonst kommt er zu spät in die schule
michael stehe jetzt auf den unterricht
fängt um viertel vor acht an
jetzt ist es schon viertel nach sieben
dein bus fährt in 15 minuten ab mami ich
bin krank ich fühle mich schlecht
mein bauch tut weh ich glaube du hast
fieber sein kopf ist ganz heiß
bleib im bett
ich komme gleich zurück
dollar
grüezi frau metzler
hier spricht meyer
ich bin die mutter von michael guten
morgen frau meier wie kann ich ihnen
helfen
mein sohn ist krank ich melde ihn vom
unterricht ab er kann heute nicht zur
schule kommen
ich verstehe was hatte denn er hat kopf
und bauchschmerzen und fieber
wir gehen gleich zum arzt ach die
hausaufgaben meine tochter kommt in die
schule können sie bitte an die
hausaufgaben mitgegeben
sie geht in die klasse 3c ja natürlich
ich gebe anna die hausaufgaben für
michael mit bitte richten sie michael
gute besserung von mir aus das werde ich
ausrichten
vielen dank für ihre hilfe frau mechler
auf wiederhören frau meier